roosevelt once said there's nothing to
fear but fear itself and that's how you
can tell that he'd never heard of the
scp foundation and face some of the
terrifying nightmares they deal with on
a daily basis and today we're taking on
the frightening task of comparing and
ranking some of the scariest scps out
there for your viewing pleasure while of
course fear is a highly subjective
concept and well over 300 videos into
our tenure we think we have a pretty
good idea of which scps bump hardest in
the night so to start us off in the
immortal words of another truly
terrifying youtuber number 15.
scp-087
is an old favorite and perhaps one of
the most famous scps out there thanks to
classified information about it being
leaked in a certain video game but
exposure hasn't diminished the potent
aura of fear that still lingers at the
bottom of this sinister staircase if
ever you find yourself in the
administrative building of a university
campus you may suddenly experience a
sense of creeping dread knowing that any
of the doors around you may lead you
into a living nightmare what awaits you
is all-consuming darkness and a
seemingly endless descent into the void
below
that is until the crying starts not long
after that you'll go from hating the
fact that you're alone in this horrible
place too desperately wishing that were
the case when 087's infamous inhabitant
the face comes up to greet you you might
even wish you'd never been born at all
but enough about a scary place you might
stumble into this next horror comes
straight to you if you need to take
regular nighttime drives for business or
pleasure then
scp-1337 is bound to be your worst
nightmare she's whispered about in urban
legends all over the world the ghostly
hitchhiker she goes by many names but
the only true name is mary tallish after
being murdered and mutilated in an
occult ritual her ghost would hitchhike
down the roads of muncie indiana and
take rides back to the home of her
parents before disappearing without a
trace a little spooky but mostly benign
until one sadistic foundation researcher
decided to attempt her neutralization by
killing off her parents in absolute
contrast to the researcher's plans this
turned mary from a ghost into a violent
demon now taking the form of her own
mutilated corpse if you see her on the
side of the road and keep driving your
horrible fate is sealed she'll appear in
your back seat her hollow eyes burning
with fury and when they find your car
crashed on the side of the road you'll
be dead and mutilated just like her but
if you think this nighttime drive is
frightening wait until you take a field
trip repeat after us i do not recognize
the bodies in the water
scp-2316 is an anomalous water source
namely a large miss shrouded lake and
the closer you get the more you'll find
yourself unable to ignore all the bodies
floating in the water you do not
recognize the bodies in the water or do
you can you tell if it's
scp-2316's powerful cognitohazardous
properties taking hold or are those
bodies really your old classmates the
only way to find out is to get closer
and the closer you get the more certain
you are yes they really are your old
friends why did you leave them here it's
been so long don't you feel guilty for
abandoning them you get closer you're in
the mist now all those familiar faces
the water laps at your ankles knees
waist shoulders neck you're smiling you
recognize the bodies in the water
they're your friends you're with them
now but horror around a dark misty lake
is to be expected during a cheerful
night at the theater not so much you've
been vaccinated after over a year of
careful social distancing so you decide
to treat yourself to some live
entertainment a play being performed by
a local community theater group the
hanged king's tragedy or scp-701
as it's known to the scp foundation
however your classy evening quickly
takes a turn for the worst and into an
absolute nightmare when a strange bound
hooded figure appears on the stage from
there not only will the content of the
play become more disturbing from murders
to hangings but the behavior of the
audience will take an even more depraved
turn it will erupt into horrifying
violence and chaos as seemingly normal
people go into a lethal frenzy driven
mad by the cursed play every performance
of
scp-701 is doomed to become a harrowing
mass killing let's go from the stage to
a horror who prefers to stay out of the
limelight he waits in the dark pacing
hiding
weeping if ever you see his face there
will be hell to pay that's right it's
the infamous shy guy scp-009
from its look to its actions this
homicidal maniac is built from nightmare
fuel he's freakishly tall with
disportionately long limbs and a gaunt
stretchy face with a terrifyingly large
mouth and if ever you see so much as a
photo of that face you'll find out
exactly what he can do with it
scp-096 will make a beeline for you at
breakneck speeds no chasm or barrier or
ocean will stop him no weapon will slow
him down he will find you and he will
murder you your family won't even have
any remains to bury when he's done but
you don't need to look at our next
monster's face for him to terrify you
honestly he doesn't even really need one
first things first stay put and don't
open the door what do you think we're
just paranoid just be quiet and listen
can you hear it the deep labored
breathing the subtle scratching against
the wood even though you can't see it
you know what it looks like it's waiting
listening it's long dirty teeth chatter
with anticipation whatever you do
don't open the door
scp-303
also known as the doorman is a
mysterious creature with the ability to
manifest behind doors or other entryway
barriers opposite a sentient observer
always causing such intense feelings of
dread in his victims that they find it
impossible to open the door or entryway
barrier this fear is so great that some
people have starved to death rather than
open the door to get food he's just that
terrifying but you'll be grateful that
303 was keeping the door closed if it
means you can avoid going to our next
terrifying location we have a few
questions for you first have you been
having any strange dreams lately
interesting secondly do you remember
going to a place called cragglewood park
in your youth it was a strange wondrous
and slightly unsettling theme park full
of grinning singing trees and the most
beautiful carousel you've ever seen just
two more questions are you an only child
have you always been an only child if
you've ever visited
scp-2571 cragglewood park you may have
difficulty answering these questions
because this whimsical fever dream
beckons pairs of siblings to its twisted
carnival of smiling trees but only one
of these two siblings ever leaves and
the other becomes just one more giggling
singing nightmare tree sleep tight kids
but that's not the most dangerous entity
coming after your kids what are your
kids watching in an era of unprecedented
internet access it's a harder question
to answer than ever but you better pray
they're not watching scp-993
or they'll end up as prey for a sinister
entity known as bobble the clown with
bobble it's less a question of what
he'll do to your kids and more about
what he'll make your kids do to you
themselves and anyone else unlucky
enough to cross them under his influence
his educational programming will teach
your kids about things like murder
self-mutilation cannibalism performing
dark rituals and believe us they will be
extremely receptive to his teachings
leave your children with bobble playing
on the tv
and they'll be little monsters before
you know it but enough about little
monsters how about a really really big
one scp-1128
also known as the aquatic horror is a
massive underwater predator with unique
info-hazardous properties once you've
had the beast described to you you're in
its sights forever and you're not safe
near any body of water the monster has
devoured its victims in oceans lakes
pools bathtubs puddles and in the case
of one extremely unlucky victim the
glass of water he was drinking from it
is a ruthless and terrifying predator
and once it has you you'll be gorillally
devoured in seconds they say the one way
to escape it is to take amnestic
treatment and forget you ever knew about
the beast but does that really make you
feel safe will anything make you feel
safe now next time you're straying a
little too close to the water but at
least
scp-1128 will devour you quickly our
next horror loves to take his time
scp-106 the old man capable of walking
through walls burning flesh with a touch
and most terrifyingly of all dragging
you into his private torture dimension
where he has absolute power there he'll
taunt and hurt you for as long as he
pleases until you're little more than a
desiccated husk once he selects his
targets almost nothing can stop him in
his pursuit of them save only for the
prospect of causing more suffering
elsewhere but while 106 takes his time
our next unstoppable sadist kills whole
extended families at once if you plan on
having a christening a wedding or a
funeral anytime soon well we hope you're
prepared to plan for plenty more
funerals especially if your cousin
johnny is in attendance though the
foundation would be more inclined to
call him scp-2852
he's the ultimate terrifying party
crasher and when he manifests in your
family function there's nothing anybody
can do to save you he'll turn these
sacred days into orgies of violence and
terror arcane rituals murder cannibalism
self-mutilation and more even if you
manage to survive one of these events
you will be forever haunted many die
early all live unfortunate and unhappy
lives many turn to violence and murder
as they cannot cope with the horrors
they've seen and worst of all you never
know when it's going to be your turn
after all cousin johnny is everybody's
cousin but when it comes to body horror
johnny doesn't hold a candle to our next
entry these monsters make your standard
walking dead look positively cuddly
scp-610 the flesh that hates
scp-610 the flesh that hates is a circus
nightmare that's thankfully confined to
a desolate community in siberia but if
it ever got out then dying before the
change took hold would be a happy
reprieve this hyper-infectious virus
transforms you into a straight up
monster a fleshy abomination with only
one prerogative spread the infection
further and if ever you were unlucky
enough to be on the receiving end of
610's pathogenic payload the monster you
become couldn't even be called a twisted
shadow of who you once were the flesh is
eternal it wants to bring us all into
its hateful embrace but there is one
body horror event more disturbing than
610. why because it went global learn to
embrace the dark friends
fear the light the words that ushered in
the incomprehensible nightmare of
scp-001 when day breaks an xk class end
of the world scenario where the sun
itself becomes a terrifying anomaly
exposure to sunlight caused its victims
to melt while still remaining alive
these blobs of living human flesh would
then coagulate into giant amoeba-like
masses hell bent on dragging others out
into the light most horrors on this list
lurk in the darkness there are few
things more profoundly unnatural than
evil not just living in the light but
being the light itself though true
horror can often hide in unlikely places
just like the next entry on our list
scp-4666 the yule man the king of
turning christmas cheer into christmas
fear and making krampus look like jolly
old saint nick himself in comparison
every year this yuletide monster selects
a new series of victims that he stalks
over the christmas season preparing to
make his grand entrance in the very
heart of winter and when he does enter
if you're lucky he'll just leave a
morbid toy made from the flesh of his
previous victims if you're unlucky he'll
torture and then butcher the whole
family in ways too horrible to imagine
before kidnapping the youngest child
this child will then be forced into
slavery in the yule man's twisted
workshop and if he doesn't eat them when
he gets hungry he'll make their fellow
children turn them into toys when they
get too weak or injured to work
themselves it doesn't get much more evil
than this but we can think of one that
frightens us just a little bit more
scp-20
also known as the slow burn sloth
surprised perhaps you've never heard of
this one before and you're wondering how
it could beat out classics like scp-096
and
scp-106 after all it's just a memetic
image of a man in the janky sloth
costume that sometimes appears in media
both recorded and live but if you do
happen to see this strange little image
everything you hold dear is about to be
taken away from you the scariest things
about a lot of the monsters on this list
is the way that they'll kill you the
scary thing about 2774 is that it won't
kill you at all you'll just wish it had
when the memetic infection takes hold
you'll slowly lose all cognitive
functions you can no longer move or even
think on your own your body is on slow
motion autopilot for the majority of the
day save for 150 seconds every 24 hours
during those lucid periods victims will
often beg to be put out of their misery
the slow burn sloth isn't gory shocking
or sadistic it's worse it'll trap you in
the prison of your own mind reducing you
to less than an infant but fully
conscious of all you've lost your own
little sunken place where the only
release is death and frankly scp
explained fans we can't think of many
things scarier than that now go check
out waldo finds you
scp-4885 find him and
scp-2521 redacted and infohazard scps
explained for terrifying scps